hey this is pressure Walker today I
wanted to share with you a fun little
challenge even though it's tricky I
think many of you who are subscribed or
clever enough to figure it out on the
screen is a sentence and the challenge
for you is to identify all of the errors
in the sentence can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution so the first four mistakes and
the sentence are fairly easy to figure
out the first is that the word are is
repeated the second is that the word two
is repeated the third is that the word
mix takes is a misspelling of the word
mistakes and the fourth is that the
sentence is missing a punctuation mark
and should end with the period the
puzzle now
is where is the fifth mistake so you
have to think about this a little bit
carefully it's not a grammatical mistake
but rather a logical mistake it turns
out the sentence itself is a logical
paradox as the sentence has only four
mistakes the statement that the sentence
has five mistakes is false and that
could be said to be a fifth mistake
however once you add this error the
sentence then indeed has five total
mistakes which would mean the sentence
only has a total of four mistakes as you
can see the logic will never resolve did
you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media app
Richelle Larker and if you liked this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description